[Applaudissements]
parce qu'on va faire dans 5 minutes donc
je peux vous dire c'est pas ce qu'on va
faire
voilà c'est rassurant donc voilà ne rit
pas gilles verdez qui là qu'il a cherché
ou qu'il la méritait bien sûr que non
abbas est ce que vous avez l'honneur
mais c'est parce que en fait ça a été
coupé par rapport à tout ce que j'ai dit
mais je n'en sais ce que je dis c'est
quand on est en loges même moi quand je
suis en loge est quelqu'un qui débarque
comme ça avec une caméra je vais mal
l'accueillir si vous auriez vu tchad les
humanitaires ne chérit oui c'est pesant
mais bon c'est joey starr joey starr a
été très bien mais les comment il est
passé
on sait bien qu'en l'asticot tard il va
pas lui faire un gros bisou sur le fond
c'est à dire je t'aime
voilà bon on va pas revenir juste loana
franchement je vous aime bien et depuis
longtemps mais reconnaissez reconnaissez
les yeux dans les yeux en de là vous
avez dit une belle connerie le geste
était trop fort trop s'embêter joey
starr vous saviez qu'elle ait à voir
quelque chose d'accord mais alors non
mais je le prends pour moi
là c'est moi qui lui ai dit allez faire
un petit bisou à l'instar donc là c'est
de ma faute al wahda vous pouvez dire
hanouna est un con ça nous dire en sera
de même avec ma wii non mais allégé les
revoilà
et on a essayé jauger si loana traite
hanouna doucouré avait envoyé le casse
pipe cela c'est vrai oui je l'envoyais
au casse pipe
salut à sigi l'artiche dis la vérité je
vous envoyer au casse-pipe voilà c'est
la prochaine fois j'irai moi-même
elle est gentille mais la tension givet
moi ça se finit en bagarre générale à
l'égard ça se finirait